it's springtime you're outside more it
is time for sunscreen but stay away from
the chemical sunscreens with ingredients
that can irritate skin cause hormonal
disruption or Worse instead use mineral
sunscreen by Ginger armor which is just
as effective you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at gingerarmor.com the link is
down below
we start today with some extraordinarily
sad audio that has been released of a
conversation with Democratic senator
Dianne Feinstein this is a really tough
story to do because this is not an
ageist program in principle and this is
not about ageism this is about
competency
and it appears as though Senator Dianne
Feinstein back from three months out of
the Senate due to health issues has no
memory of having been gone for the last
three months calls for her to resign are
surging again
and we have to be able to you know on
the one hand we have empathy for Dianne
Feinstein and her family and as people
of course and we also recognize that
it is not clear Dianne Feinstein is
currently fit to serve in the United
States Senate now for those of you who
will write in and say David Trump wasn't
fit to serve and he was President for
four years
that's not really what this is about so
we're going to play some audio
there were reports of this conversation
we now have the audio Senator Dianne
Feinstein back from an absence of
several months while battling shingles
is interviewed by Benjamin oreskis of
the Los Angeles Times and she appears to
have no memory whatsoever of having been
away for those three months
the well wishes what have you heard what
have I heard about what about your
return how have they felt about you no I
haven't been gone okay
um you should follow me I haven't been
gone I've been working you've been
working from home is what you're saying
oh I've been here
um what do you say to uh Californians
like rocano say you should resign
so um at that point Feinstein
um uh whisked away
um Democratic Congressman rocana again
repeats this call for Dianne Feinstein
to resign after this incident
sfgate.com reporting rocana was the
first member of Congress to call for
Feinstein's resignation and he is
echoing that call a day after uh
reporters had this encounter where she
appeared to not remember that she had
been absent for three months
uh this is a really tough situation and
it's it's getting ugly and there really
aren't great options and the best option
that many are talking about is that it
is Feinstein's family who should
convince her to resign Gavin Newsom the
governor of California would get to
select a replacement
um and I don't remember based on it's in
California whether there is or isn't a
special election depends on the number
of days until the next election I
believe because it's more than six
months until the 2024 election there
would be a special election I think
although I may be wrong we'll double
check that but if it is not the options
according to the U.S Constitution for
removing a senator from Office are
expulsion or resignation and expulsion
would be a formal vote with two-thirds
of the members of the Senate present and
voting
uh in favor of uh of removal resignation
is of course voluntary it doesn't
require a vote it's just up to the
senator and there is no provision for a
recall this is a really sad and tough
situation and as I've said before Dianne
Feinstein has an incredibly storied
career in the Senate she is the
longest-serving Democratic member of the
Senate right now and I believe the
oldest by by a few months older than
Chuck Grassley she'll be 90 uh in a few
weeks and
this has been going on for years is the
truth okay and at some point you have to
just say this is what it is
um Dianne Feinstein reportedly
regularly doesn't remember meeting
people that she sees regularly and works
with regularly there are all of these
examples of Dianne Feinstein at Senate
hearings where she will read a question
off of a piece of paper it's not super
clear if she totally gets the question
but after the witness answers she asks
the exact same question question a
second time this isn't serving anyone
this isn't serving democracy this isn't
serving the Democratic party who's had
judicial uh nominations from Joe Biden
held up because of Feinstein's absence
she's on the Judiciary Committee so at
the end of the day I don't know what the
mechanism is here but we have to be able
to look at a situation and assess it for
what it is now people have been writing
to me saying David there should be an
upper limit on age for senators or an
upper limit on the number of years
you're allowed to serve or whatever
listen Maybe maybe those things can all
be explored where we are right now is
that this is the situation and growing
calls for Feinstein to resign the audio
is troubling and it's sad and it's where
we are right now
Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
had both endorsees lose on Tuesday and
of course the failed former and wannabe
future president Donald Trump is trying
to capitalize on this the truth is
Trump's trothing aside
the truth is that Ron DeSantis is not
only
increasingly low in the polling
he is also visibly losing notably losing
political Capital as two endorsees have
lost let's look at exactly what happened
the hill reporting DeSantis sees both
endorsed candidates lose DeSantis
stepped into the Kentucky Republican
gubernatorial primary to back former U.N
Ambassador Kelly Kraft endorsing Craft
on Election Day a little bit late in the
game as polling in the run-up to the
election projected Kraft lost to
attorney general Daniel Cameron
Trump backed Cameron whatever you
believe about Trump's endorsement record
and it's quite mediocre overall this is
very clearly a public win for Trump
um
the other example of course is uh what
was the other example actually don't
have it here uh who else did did to say
I don't know oh uh oh I see here
Democrats flip mayor's office Republican
Daniel Davis succeeds mayor Lenny Curry
desantis-backed Davis but Curry won
there as well so Trump immediately
seizes on this as I would be doing as
well because this just looks very bad
for DeSantis Trump posting to his
platform truth Central quote wow in a
big upset the de sanctimonious-backed
Republican candidate for mayor of
Jacksonville Florida lost this is a
shocker
if they would have asked me to capital E
endorse he would have won easily Too
Proud to do so fools this is a big loss
for the Republican party remember Rob
only won because of me he now calls Ron
DeSantis Rob then continuing to post
truths quote de sanctimonious lost
Jacksonville in Kentucky last night not
good and then lastly quote
congratulations to a quote star in
Kentucky Daniel Cameron who easily won
the Republican nomination for governor
he had my Capital C complete and total
endorsement the de sanctimonious backed
candidate came in a distant third Ron's
magic is gone he also lost shockingly in
Jacksonville last night mayor and the
truth is you know Trump lies all the
time
but Trump is rightly assessing that
desantises I I was going to call it a
campaign but it's not yet really a
campaign desantises would-be campaign is
in complete and total free fall I
reported to you yesterday that DeSantis
polling had collapsed all the way down
to just over 20 percent in the
Republican primary and overnight
DeSantis is now below 20 percent
just barely at 19.9 and as I've said
before with Trump surging now at 56.
remember a few weeks ago Trump was at
43. if Trump's at 43 you look at that
and you say hey if I just get the
non-trump vote if Trump has 43 there's
57 out there available if I can get that
I can win the primary without taking a
single vote from Trump
now is all the way up to 56 percent
when Trump is at 56 percent you now have
to contend with the reality that if you
scoop up somehow all of the non-trump
vote
you only have 44 and so then you have to
justify how can I take votes from Trump
and I don't know how DeSantis does it
that's where we are right now the
DeSantis campaign truly in free fall
that being said interestingly the
reports are that DeSantis still plans to
announce a candidacy and as I've said
before
I can see both sides on the one hand I
don't see what the Santa's path to
Victory is right now on the other hand
if you're DeSantis and you have sick
offense around you as many of these
people often do you might be saying to
yourself the fact that I even have 19.9
and I haven't announced tells me this
may be my shot sure I could wait until
2028 when I guess DeSantis would be 48
years old I could do that
but anything could happen between now
and then my I might be trying with five
percent in 2028 I have 20 right now
maybe Trump gets indicted again or again
or again gets arrested a couple more
times it pulls him off the campaign
Trail Anything could happen maybe I need
to be there sort of like the Seinfeld
episode where uh I think it was Jerry
who says listen I'm just going to be
there for her
after some kind of a breakup and then
I'll just be there and who knows if
she's interested then I'll just be there
this may be quite frankly desantis's
approach I only have 20 percent
I don't know how I'll take supporters
from Trump but if things go wrong I will
just be there I don't think it looks
good for DeSantis reports are he may
announce within the next seven to ten
days we will watch it one uh quick
reminder Monday Memorial Day we are
doing a one day membership special the
goal is to kick start membership
uh and we will be doing it with an
incredible discount code if you'd like
to be notified of how to take advantage
of this membership special on Monday
morning Memorial Day all you have to do
is get on my mailing list at
davidpackman.com
it is Springtime it's getting warm we
are all spending more time outside many
sunscreens contain elements that the FDA
has warned about oxybenzone Ava benzone
homo sailate and others these are
absorbed into your bloodstream they can
irritate sensitive skin they can be
hormone disruptors I just stay away from
them and I use mineral sunscreens I do
the same when I put sunscreen on my baby
daughter and our sponsor Ginger armor
makes the world's thinnest 100 mineral
sunscreen it works for all skin types
not just gingers as the name might
suggest it rubs in clear on all skin
tones feels like nothing is on with SPF
50 plus protection Ginger armor also
acts as a plant-based moisturizer with
21 simple gentle ingredients from plants
and minerals it's good for you it's good
for the planet it's more affordable than
other sunscreens with similar quality
ingredients I also love that it's a
small business made in the U.S and they
donate one percent of all sales to the
one percent for the planet charity go to
gingerarmor.com use code Pacman for 15
off the link is down below
remember that the David pakman show is
an audience supported program we do an
extra show every day for our members
it's called the bonus show you can sign
up at joinpakman.com you can also use
the coupon code 24 starts now that's the
numbers 2-4 starts now all one word no
spaces cram it all together uh lowercase
capitalize doesn't really matter
joinpakman.com coupon code 24 Starts Now
read about the benefits do the thing all
right this is going to be super
interesting Adam mockler who has a
YouTube channel recently went out in
Iowa at the failed Trump rally remember
the one that got canceled either because
of weather or because not enough people
showed up Trump was scheduled to speak
and Adam spoke to Trump supporters and
this is really really really good stuff
but it is very scary
the topic of attitudes towards trans
people came up significantly
conspiracy conspiracy theories and
conspiratorial thinking came up
significantly so let's just get right
into it Adam does a really good job here
this is Adam machler who you can find at
youtube.com at sign Adam mockler let's
just jump in and Brace yourselves Okay
this may not be appropriate for children
I think I should say hanging hookers
right what percent of Americans do you
think are transgender
I would say
before it was cool to be transgender or
well before it was probably like I would
say 1.5 and now it's probably like 20
okay this is something we see when
um anti-semitic conspiracy theorists are
asked
how many Jews do you think there are and
very often they'll say you know in the
world they'll say oh it's like five
percent of the population or it's ten
percent twenty percent thirty percent
and then you go actually it's it's 0.2
percent of the global population is
Jewish one of the things that's common
is folks who see groups as problematic
will dramatically overstate their
prevalence in the population the the um
uh
islamophobic folks well if you say oh I
don't know like 10 of the US must be
Muslim or something like that
really common thing twenty percent it's
still 0.5 oh okay okay I was pretty
close on 1.5
let me ask you this if an adult goes to
the doctor with gender dysphoria and
they try to decide on a treatment do you
think the government should be able to
step in and stop that oh no no not not
if they're paying for it as long as you
know they have their own insurance that
they're paying for I don't think a state
you know uh health insurance should have
to pay for your you know your gender
reassignment so you're okay with people
getting gender affirming care though oh
yeah yeah as long as I'm not paying for
it now this sounds sort of open-minded
right I mean okay but what's interesting
about it is this whole thing of am I
paying for it he says as long as State
Insurance isn't paying for it well you
know one of the realities is the way
Insurance Works everybody pays in based
on what actuaries believe is expected to
be the total amount of uh spending
that's going to be done on procedures
and and services of different kinds in a
sense even with private insurance
if gender affirming care is covered
everybody who's part of that risk pool
is in a sense paying for it now I know
this guy doesn't understand that he's
not thinking of that and he says that
it's not it's not the procedures I have
a problem with it's who's paying for it
but the reality is that it's a little
more complicated than just as long as
I'm not paying for it if insurance
covers it at all
then it's being paid for in shared
responsibility by everyone participating
in that risk pool but you know okay
it's it's at least he's open-minded and
saying it shouldn't be illegal
um all right let's continue then uh then
Adam speaks to a woman who says the
country is more divided than ever and
then immediately brings up the Biden
crime family which isn't a thing with
absolutely no understanding that part of
the reason the country's divided is
because people like her are saying
things like Biden crime family she also
says uh cannabis causes mental issues
let's listen I did
marched when I
don't know any Democrats say that it was
their responsibility or they did this
sure have you looked at the records the
actual information that we found about
Biden and his crime family we've found
about the Biden crime family wait
we're drugs I believe that children are
able to get a hold of nowadays that
would be far fewer mental issues what
kind of drugs
pot for one you really you disagree with
smoke you best your sweet bippy I grew
up with kids that when it was just
coming in and I saw them make complete
idiots of themselves now on cannabis
yeah it's not a lie to say marijuana can
have negative effects for some people on
Mental Health depending on the person
the amount the frequency of use the type
of marijuana product and some people
cannabis causes anxiety or paranoia
there are instances of temporary
psychosis that can be caused by by
cannabis in very very high doses the
truth is that all these things are very
rare and we have lots of legal products
like alcohol that are arguably far worse
but they actually are really morally
concerned that you have to understand
this if you show my guesses if you
showed this woman the data on alcohol
and cannabis
uh and you said hey look but look at
alcohol there's a moral
uh connotation that folks like her have
when it comes to cannabis and that's um
that that's that's a big part of this
let's continue now I'm sort of skipping
around now we go
um
oh this is really wild okay let's just
jump into this one then we'll talk about
it that transgender has just been
publicized uh just like other
distract us from
um when it's more of a mental issue
mental health issue well if it's a
mental health the argument here is we've
been distracted by trans trans really is
just a mental health issue okay well
let's explore that issue then wouldn't
that follow that treatment would improve
these people's quality of life so you're
for gender affirming care no
trans is a mental issue okay so then we
should provide the treatments that
reduce the the mental issues right uh
yeah oh like during their firming care
no not that there's tons of studies that
people who receive gender affirming care
have a way better quality of life than
people who don't you've just seen it
from the one side or are you seeing both
sides of it now that's an interesting
question right
randomized controlled trials
peer-reviewed show this but her question
is which side are you getting that from
well it's what the science shows well
tell me your side no I'm just saying
have you seen the research on just the
one side or are you seeing it from both
this is that that's such a critical
thing here right the idea that
it's all just opinions okay yeah
research but it's like one person's
opinion research and another person's
opinion research as opposed to
we have a scientific foundation for how
we can evaluate what is to be believed
that is separated from our opinions
about it very difficult for lots of
these folks to understand that idea it's
all sort of an opinion isn't it opposite
of gender affirming care I guess would
be conversion therapy and there's zero
studies showing that conversion therapy
works actually that increases the
suicide rate of trans people right
I I don't know the static statistics now
now she doesn't know and this is a very
common Retreat you go forward and you
assert assert assert assert you then
have pushback which is well here's the
data I don't really know the data let's
move on that
[Music]
what makes you think Trump will be able
to beat Biden in 2024 when he already
lost zoom in 2020. well he didn't lose
to him in 2012. you don't think so no
they're completely rigged Biden is just
a puppet anyway now this is where it
gets really crazy I dare you to follow
this so so far she's asserted Trump won
and Biden's a puppet but who's the
puppeteer get ready to I hope people
like pretzels because this is a
completely a total logic pretzel
who's who's controlling them
the white hats
the white hats the white hat can you
define who the who those people are that
would be our military our generals and
our current and sitting president of
trump he's our commander-in-chief still
you think Trump is still a sitting
president yes
you think Trump is currently making all
the decisions in the country
so would you blame the current inflation
on Trump
yes because
where we would have been all right at
least she's consistent she's saying
listen Trump's the president and
everything that's going on can be blamed
on Trump okay at least that's some level
of consistency I'm not blaming him but
in order for everybody to actually start
waking up
and that's gonna come down the pipeline
if Hillary would have gotten in and they
would have been able to do their new
world order this is what we were going
to get in the Border crisis that's also
on Trump
have you been to the Border no have you
no so how do we actually know if the if
the wall was actually done how are they
getting in so this is where we go into
something that unfortunately happens
often when folks like this or are
questioned about their beliefs
they go to how do we know they they
become almost metaphysical they become
uh philosophers of of epistemology how
do we know anything what is the nature
of reality they become Deepak Chopra all
of a sudden is it really a crisis or is
it just crisis actors
I I don't think there's a crisis at the
border honestly I don't think so either
you think people are at the border
acting like immigrants correct well
what's the purpose of this
to wake more people up to what
to seen
we would be going socialists
in a communist country so now it's just
the word salad now she's just it's
coming out of her like a projectile
vomit Socialist Communist crisis actor
this is barely English it's just words
it I recognize the words but it's not
making any sense that's not what
America's about the okay
that's really serious and what I want
people to think about is
okay it's funny it's entertaining okay
that could be you know they talk about
teachers left in dusk that could be
someone I don't know what what job this
woman has if any
that could be someone's teacher
that could be I mean like I guess she
could be your accountant right as as
unhinged as she is
she might be able to hold it together
and be a CPA I don't know but there's
tens of millions of these folks now we
go to another guy who goes into
um election conspiracies let me get fast
past his introduction here's a guy who
he has his own series of oh January 6th
conspiracy to get the Democrats and all
the Deep State out and we need to take
back the country for the people yeah
peacefully no violence no violence so
you disagree with what happened on
January 6th it was not an Insurrection
we were set up by whom Democrats in a
deep State and people was there FBI was
you don't think there's a part of
individual responsibility to do with it
though so like if you make the decision
to walk into the capitol break glass
into Riot don't you think it might be
justified to be charged with something
yes if you break the law of course
there's consequences to Breaking the Law
now you get a group of people I don't
care who it is it could be Christians
whatever you get someone or a couple
people in there that are instigators
they're going to get the whole crowd to
go even Christians I love that even
Christians might be able to either
convince or be convinced in this sort of
mob mentality but you know these are
sort of like it's again it's this
projectile vomit who did the setting up
on January 6. well he mentions FBI
antifa uh Democrats I think he said it
they all I guess work together or
separately with the same goal it was
extraordinarily organized it makes no
sense but it doesn't matter it takes one
flame to get the can of gas to burn yes
now there was people there yes that
should not have done what they did the
disruption should not have happened if
you get caught on it prosecute you all
right so now we're going to go to
another woman who says the election was
stolen because
[Music]
because the courts are rigged a lot of
those judges were appointed by Trump
though
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a lot of undercurrent things
that are going on simple how does Adam
not understand
so you think Trump appointed over 60
judges that were part of the swamp
Maybe
doesn't that reflect poorly on Trump's
judgment no
because look at look at all these people
that were wearing masks yeah of course
they pulled too
no
no no oh I think that they were what is
she talking about this I I've talked
about this before these are endless
special pleadings right uh that I've
given the example before hey you know
what guys right here in the studio with
me
um there's an invisible tiger it's here
you just can't see it so I say oh okay
well it's invisible but it still has
mass right so let's put baby powder on
the floor so even though we can't see
the tiger when it walks around it'll
move the baby powder and we'll prove
that it's here no it's an invisible
weightless tiger
okay well so how about this it needs to
eat right let's put some beautiful
steaks down for the tiger and then even
if we can't see the tiger and even if
the tiger doesn't have any mass and
isn't going to disturb the baby powder
we'll see the food move it's gonna need
the food no it's an invisible weightless
tiger that also doesn't eat and then you
go further and further and it doesn't
matter now the look on This Woman's face
you see she sort of is starting to
realize she seems kind of like a
uh not all of them have that recognition
necessarily all right last guy here this
guy says there should be no trans people
now how you get to that I don't know I
don't know what he means there should
well who's going to get rid of them I
don't know but they get into an
interesting discussion actually about
gender identity that almost like it
almost goes in an interesting Direction
Take a Look that we're humanistic uh
yeah I think there should be no
transgenders I'm pretty sure there's
only two different genders that are born
and that gives two different types of
sex so
I he's pretty sure
there are only two types of genders that
are born
and that gives you two types of sex
mixing uh genitalia with gender
expression admits he's only pretty sure
this is what we're dealing with and
listen he gets to vote and good for him
right I'm not suggesting restrictions on
voting we just have to understand these
folks vote and if we don't vote these
are the sorts of ideas that end up being
reflected uh in the leaders that we
choose but even with there being two
genders that can still fit under the
transgender worldview because you're
just switching from generally masculine
features to feminine features a woman
has a female reproductive organs and a
male has male reproductive organs and
that's about it if you look at people's
genitals when you're figuring out what
do they call them sir or ma'am sir
please show me what you have there or do
you generally look at a vague set of
social characteristics
uh you can just by walking around you
can tell by the way of their voices you
can just just what's more about your
morals then what's morally the right in
this world so you can look at people and
know if they're transgender based off
their morals this is funny but it's very
sad
it's very sad and it's very scary you
know the world looks at this and we have
a lot of international viewers every
time we do this people write to me they
say David
what has happened to the United States
is it an education issue is it a
cultural issue this this is crazy
a person knows if they're men or women
and that they know their morals and know
if it's right and I totally agree to be
honest is a big thing
um we're all about honesty in this
country so they know that I didn't know
not from looking at the last presidency
I could have fooled me they're a woman
nor generally you'll know if they're a
woman just by the way they walk the way
the way they're they're this sounds
pro-trans to me though so you're saying
if somebody knows they're a woman and
they walk around with features that are
looking like a woman then they can be
considered a woman
uh no it they a woman certainly went
over with a woman in a male he doesn't
want to go over it again
[Music]
so there it is uh really really good job
there by Adam mockler and we'll link to
Adam's Channel this is good stuff
because he's he's going a little deeper
than you sometimes see
people go and one of the things I've
told you sometimes happens in political
discussions is folks can go one talking
point deep or maybe two and then it all
falls apart and then it's just words
come out that they heard Trump say but
they don't make sentences that we can
identify in any reasonable sense really
scary it is funny it is funny but it's
scary and sad more than anything else
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com join pacman.com
it's great to Welcome to the program
today Tim Maudlin who's the founder and
director of the John Bell Institute for
the foundations of physics and also
professor of philosophy at New York
University really appreciate your time
today
thanks for having me so let's let's get
into metaphysics a little bit and give
some some in our audience some tools
with which to understand this concept
very often people on the internet love
making videos about metaphysics and they
seem to have no idea what we're even
talking about so so you know one analogy
that I've used and you tell me whether
this gets us in the right direction if
we want to understand
how the moon got to exist and where it
is
gravity would be part of of
understanding that metaphysics would
look at how did Gravity get created was
there a before gravity is that is that
an example of what we talk about when we
say physics versus metaphysics well
unfortunately just the language physics
and metaphysics makes it sound like what
you just said a lot of people use it
that way historically that's not what it
is at all okay metaphysics there was a
document that came down to us from
Aristotle that a later editor called the
metaphysics Aristotle never used the
term and what he's doing in that is
looking at what we call ontology or just
the general theory of what exists
carried out at the most General high
level scale right so not geez there you
know is there a rock over here but are
there rocks at all and what are rocks
made of so from that point of view
it's not that that you go beyond physics
to do metaphysics I actually have a book
called The metaphysics within physics
because physics makes postulates about
at a fundamental level what exists
that's part of metaphysics now maybe not
everything is physical so metaphysics
would go further than that if they're
non-physical things but part of it is
just the basic picture of what exists
physically now if gravity exists
physically okay yeah gravity is part of
it is there a story about where gravity
came from maybe maybe not maybe that's
just kind of ground level stuff once you
get down to the law of gravity there's
no further account of that that's the
the bottom level of everything
when we think about things like the
relationship between mind and body which
can have religious aspects to the
discussion scientific philosophical
Consciousness Free Will these sorts of
things are are these all conversations
that include both what we might consider
traditional hard science as well as
metaphysics or are they only that
depending on the preconceived notions
one brings to the conversation
no I mean the sorts of questions you're
asking certainly the mind-body problem
uh
involves fundamental metaphysical
questions if you think there is a
non-physical Soul some people do some
people don't if you do then there's an
issue of how it can interact with a
physical body right and that the
interaction would have to go both ways
if you think there isn't then you have
to say well how is it that just physical
stuff doing something could give rise to
Consciousness and awareness that's a
very deep problem as well so there's no
easy answers here there are different
answers and each answer kind of involves
its own uh questions that that that run
on from it so yeah I mean metaphysics
certainly gets involved in those kinds
of questions when I've talked to
scientists about the question what was
there before the universe
answers obviously are always couched and
we don't actually know but one question
is was there really a before the
universe which is a hard thing to think
about because it seems as if you
understand time linearly that there must
have been some before some beginning or
something like that what what does
metaphysics have to add to that question
well it's not that metaphysics is going
to ride to the rescue and and provide
answers to this I mean the questions you
ask again are good questions
is there anything before let's say this
universe now one possible answer to that
is yeah there was another universe and
before that maybe another one and before
that maybe another and then there's a
question of how one arises out of
another maybe you say as you say one
possible answer is look there was no
before this universe
um and that might be because time goes
on forever or it might be that time
doesn't even go on forever but
nonetheless there's only so much of it
you sort of there's only a limited
amount this is the kind of standard Big
Bang Theory you go back
13.7 billion years and there is nothing
before that so it's not that that came
out of anything earlier there was no
earlier these are different answers
right and and
cosmologists have proposed different
theories that answer these questions in
different ways it's not as if
metaphysicians have some magic wand that
they're going to give you the right
answer if you're well trained in
philosophy you can at least delineate
look there's this answer there's this
answer there's this answer let's see how
they differ let's see what observations
might bear on this and questions like
that I think one of the areas where lay
people sometimes come up against I don't
know if frustration or despair or
existential crises is the right term but
with some of these questions what
becomes tough is that it can seem as
though
you either have to say I'm going to try
to answer some of these questions simply
with science because that's the only
place where the scientific method exists
and that's all I'm comfortable with in
terms of uh confidence in what we either
do know or don't know or I have to look
at a different path altogether which
would be a philosophy metaphysics Etc
and that can be frustrating because some
people feel like I'm kind of
pre-selecting where the end point for me
is going to be in some of these
questions by choosing one of these two
paths almost like a fork in the road is
that an understandable frustration but
more importantly is it an accurate uh
critique or or observation maybe is the
right word so I I think you have
something particular in mind there and
let me just point it out because you say
oh there's the scientific way and then
there are other ways well I'm saying if
someone feels that way are they right or
is that not the right interpretation or
understanding the the first thing I
would say is sort of any discipline
where you provide what we think as good
reasons to believe what you're proposing
yeah count as a kind of science
sometimes that's experimental or
observational but notice when we divide
the university into the Arts and
Sciences the math departments and the
Sciences right yeah because it works on
observations but because it works by
arguments by proofs right you say look I
have a reason that I can give to you for
for accepting this answer from that
point of view anything that really has
good evidence any anybody that's putting
forward good evidence for what they're
claiming is doing science whatever else
you call it and if something doesn't
count as science then you're just saying
well I'm putting forward opinions and I
have no good reasons for them and I
would say well that's not such a great
thing to do now there are limits to
science there may be things that you'd
like to know that we're just not in a
position to know and if there are there
are I mean you just have to live you
know live with the limitations of the
world
what are in your mind some of the most
interesting questions or problems that
are being looked at
um in in terms of metaphysics and
philosophy right now that maybe maybe
familiar to our audience or may not be
well since I specialize in foundations
of physics the one you mentioned like
how do is there a beginning to the
entire universe Cosmos and if so what
was it like and could there be anything
that we would count as an explanation
for why it was like that I think that's
a very interesting question there are
much more detailed questions about how
to understand quantum theory what you
you know the what picture of the world
that you can really comprehend
could result in the kind of phenomena we
see in the lab that we associate with
quantum theory they're very interesting
I mean I could go into detailed
questions there but I'm sure that would
go take us beyond the scope of this this
interview but
um I work in foundations of physics so
of course
I tend to those there are people who are
worried about how did Life Begin right
that's how how could living things have
have come out of non-living things
um and that's a very interesting
question I mean and and I've heard
interesting answers having to do with
how clay forms and you know various kind
of inorganic structures that could help
create the sorts of complexity that we
need for life and so on um that would be
in biology an interesting question
um so there there are lots of them in
different places I happen to live in the
in the physics part of it
I uh recently read a couple of books
about solipsism and one of the claims
that all of these books made was that
unlike with many other philosophies of
reality and time
there's been no refutation satisfactory
refutation of the idea that all we can
really be certain of is our own
existence right now as we are thinking
about it that even our memories that we
believe we have experienced
we may not actually have experienced
them they they may have been implanted
in our brains as you and I are speaking
today in other words I don't know that I
really had an apple an hour ago I have
the memory of having had that apple and
that there's been no uh satisfactory
refutation of that doesn't mean that it
is that it is true
to to choose this when it comes to
thinking about time and the passage of
time Etc what what is someone who do the
does the work you do think about such an
assertion well let me just check because
there's a little linguistic question I
have you said you read books about
solipsism did you mean that or
skepticism because it sounded like you
were right I meant solipsism you meant
solipsism well solipsism is a view it's
a very definite view it sort of says the
only thing that exists is me
I mean that that okay that's a possible
view it's kind of crazy
I mean there's so even Someone Like You
is comfortable refuting it by saying
it's kind of crazy well
okay if you want by a refutation and
absolute proof you're not gonna get it
okay but it's not that the solipsist has
an absolute proof of any sort that
solipsism is true so you can't you can't
give that standard to your enemies you
say you enemies you have to prove your
case Beyond any doubt and me I can just
say whatever I want right so it's a
question of burden of proof in a sense
so you know
um solipsism I mean the view that only I
exist I think has literally nothing to
say for
um of course there are things other than
me there are tables and chairs and if I
leave the room as Hume would say if I
leave the room and the fire is burning
and I come back later it's a bunch of
Ashes why because it kept burning all
the time when I wasn't there I mean
that's the obvious explanation it's not
you know you can say I could make up
maybe I'm in The Matrix maybe there's
some ETS you can always make up stuff
yes but there's no reason to believe the
stuff you make up and there's the the
whole picture we have the physical
Universe hangs together and allows you
to make predictions and explain a lot of
stuff that requires there to be more
than just me so I would say all the
evidence is in favor of it not being
just me and none of the evidence now
it's not an absolute proof okay so
you're just asking too much for an
absolute proof and reasonable people
don't demand absolute proof they go they
adjust their beliefs to where the weight
of the evidence is with many of these
questions I've asked folks like Lawrence
Krauss for example about it and and
others do you believe that it's a matter
of time until we answer some of these
toughest questions or do you think it's
possible that they will never be
answered
um I I think but you have to be prepared
for both outcomes because
we don't have the resources to answer
that the best we can say is that you
know people sometimes say look human
intelligence evolved among ape-like
creatures on the Savannah it allowed
them to survive it gave enough
intelligence to deal with that World
um what makes you think that that makes
you smart enough or have the right kind
of intelligence to deal with questions
of cosmology or whatever on the other
hand you certainly have to say well
we've done awfully well I mean we've
extended science down to to microscopic
and subatomic scales and to cosmological
scales and we understand a lot about
Galaxy formation and everything so
certainly our intellectual abilities go
far beyond what we needed just in order
to survive how far will they take us
will they take us to an end as it were
Theory that's just the Right theory that
always makes the right predictions or
will we get stuck I don't know I mean
the only way to find out is to push
forward right the only way to find out
is to figure out what we don't know now
and investigate the possible ways to go
forward and push as hard as you can to
make a a prediction about whether we'll
succeed or not
I you know I guess I tend to be kind of
optimistic but I but that's just a
character trait of mine that's not an
argument
I I share that uh cautious optimism that
that some at some point what are the
time scales we're thinking of though I
think is where it becomes a tougher
question uh we've been speaking with Tim
Maudlin who is a professor of philosophy
at New York University you have an
ongoing project you wanted to mention as
well is that right yes I did just since
I have people's attention if you're
interested in these issues um I am the
founder and director of the John Bell
Institute for the foundations of physics
we are at the moment trying to raise
money on a GoFundMe to buy a a location
where we can exist physically so if
anybody would like to help us out we
would appreciate any help you can give
us you can just uh Google John Bell
Institute to our website or the GoFundMe
John Bell Institute and it would come up
that's a John
bellinstitute.org as the website uh Tim
modlin really appreciate your time and
insights today thank you thank you
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so there
are reports of a massive shake-up coming
to the Fox News Prime Time lineup
involving Sean Hannity and Laura Ingram
and others those have not yet been
confirmed by Fox news as of this moment
so let's wait on reporting those what I
do want to tell you is that the latest
attempt at a Tucker Carlson replacement
since Tucker Carlson was fired of course
Fox News has gone through a number of
possible trial hosts this latest guy is
the worst of all of them so far so as a
reminder in the immediate aftermath of
the firing of Tucker Carlson Brian kill
Mead from Fox and Friends took a shot at
it totally milk toast just not good then
Lawrence Jones came in Lawrence Jones
notably not ready for prime time he
tried to come out aggressive asking
tough questions he looked visibly
confused about the questions he was
asking his guests it was a really big
cell phone then Trump's former press
secretary Kylie Kaylee mcenany a
completely self-absorbed to a delusional
Level Playing videos of herself speaking
at some former RNC or whatever really
really bad and now Fox news this week
tried out will Kane
I'm going to show you decoding Fox News
which is a great Twitter account to
follow decoding Fox News made a
90-second summary of a nine-minute
monologue that will Kane did at the top
of last night's show a misogynistic rant
blaming Jill Biden and Giselle fetterman
the wife of Senator John fetterman
blaming them for forcing Joe Biden and
John fetterman to take jobs they can't
handle attacking Senator Dianne
Feinstein it endlessly just did this was
the worst one yet not looking good for
Fox News if this is the best they can
come up with pressure
that is so hard to watch He's incoherent
and if we're being honest
and not worried about being kind that
was one of his better moments from
yesterday that man should not be allowed
to operate a power tool or drive a car
much less govern this country whoa but
as sad as that is for fetterman it's
more sad for the people of Pennsylvania
how did 2.5 million people vote for
fetterman because the alternative was Dr
Oz
what is going on here who is using these
people they're useful idiots for whom
for Jill Biden for Giselle fetterman for
Chuck Schumer
we here in the United States of America
were once led by strong men in America
we were led by Visionaries who not only
won a revolution against an Empire but
had the humility to limit their own
power through Eternal principles
enshrined in a constitution dear God
Titans historic Titans and globally we
were led by men who between glasses of
Brandy and Scotch stared down not only a
tyranny but also weak weaklings on their
own team in order to win a World War
you know we once had Washington and
Jefferson and Madison and now we have
Florida legislatures doing Tick-Tock
dances on The Well of their legislature
body now we have Biden now we have
fetterman now we have Feinstein and yes
for those individuals they are the
victims of ambitious spouses but
it's all their spouses that are to be
blamed so Top Line could not be less
newsworthy could not be more of a snooze
Fest to see will Kane host uh uh Tucker
Carlson's old show here's one other
funny moment he tried to defend the
actions of
um suspended NBA player John Morant and
without even looking at notes Stephen A
Smith explains to will Kane the totality
of what's gone wrong with Morant and it
will Kane just has nothing to say see on
the side of your screen he's flashing a
gun in an Instagram live video I said
earlier this week Stephen A that I don't
think he should be suspended for what
amount to dumb but legal Behavior
everyone Stephen A everyone has
disagreed with me on this count and I
know you do as well
yeah because you know you're usually
ill-informed when it comes to sports
matters that's not your Forte even
though you sound great talking about it
but then when we get to the facts you
always got some slippage there here's
the reality of the situation he's been
involved in several instances he was
involved in an incident last summer
where he allegedly got into an issue
with a high school Prospect came out of
his house with a gun there was another
issue involving a friend in Indianapolis
where after a game some kind of laser
red dot laser was being pointed in the
direction of some some folks with the
Indiana Pacers party then it was the
issue he got suspended over for eight
games that cost him over six hundred
thousand dollars now there's this he had
met with the commissioner Adam Silver
the National Basketball Association
looked him dead in his face and
essentially told them this is not me
this is not indicative of my character
and it won't happen again and yet turns
around and this kind of thing happens so
when you're looking at it in a vacuum
and you're thinking about the fact that
no laws were broken no crime was
committed and obviously he plays in the
state I don't know which car where he
was and terms of when he was in the car
for the latest incident but he plays for
the Memphis Grizzlies that's in
Tennessee and obviously in Tennessee you
don't even need a permit to carry so he
didn't break any laws or anything like
that but the NBA is a private industry
and they don't want to be associated
with that because they remember what it
was like in the 80s when the show when
the league was on tape delay will Kane
desperate to try to make some point but
he just knows nothing about this and
Stephen A Smith completely schooling him
so bottom line not ready for prime time
another failed attempt at replacing
Tucker Carlson who's relaunching his
show on Twitter I guess very soon it
will be very interesting to see What
Becomes of the new Fox News lineup but I
don't think will Kane is going to be the
steward of that new Prime Time lineup
and ratings not good Republican
Congressman clay Higgins who describes
himself as being for Law and Order
appears to have committed criminal
battery on video attacking an activist
take a look at this mediaite reports
house Republican manhandles protest who
tells him get off me you're hurting me
clay Higgins physically removed a
protester from a press conference with
Paul gozar and Lauren bobert on
Wednesday as the man screamed get off me
you're hurting me
several recordings showed Democratic
Socialist protester Jake Burdette being
pushed by Higgins out of the D.C event
as the congressman said you're out we
have the video lawyers have reviewed
this and have said to me they believe
this is Criminal battery take a look
you're a U.S congressman
[Music]
so for people just listening what we
have seen and are still watching here is
Congressman clay Higgins a radical
lunatic Republican grabbing this
individual uh forcing him uh out and
Away in the sort of bear hug shove and I
mean listen if you if you're really
about Law and Order that's a crime it's
battery and it's criminal when it's done
with the intent to harm okay unclear
injure not really clear annoy absolutely
or offend another person without their
consent Jake Burdette clearly did not
consent to being manhandled in that way
when we talk about criminal battery it
doesn't matter if it's light or it's
severe in terms of the contact if it's
unlawful and offensive and meets those
requirements then it is indeed criminal
battery if you spit on someone after an
argument document or something like that
even if they're not injured if they did
not consent to that then it's a form of
criminal battery and it's usually a
misdemeanor punishable by up to six
months in jail or a fine states have
different degrees and classifications of
battery you can have aggravated battery
sexual battery Family Violence battery
Etc but if you are for Law and Order you
can only see that and say that was a
crime committed by the Republican clay
Higgins now mehdi Hassan had a good
tweet about this where he said if a
democratic member of Congress if a squad
member did this to a conservative
protester it would be 24 7 on Fox news
for days and that's absolutely right
imagine for a second okay just imagine
for a second if AOC had done this to
some conservative protester imagine that
it was a female protester right two two
women
it would be 24 7 on Fox News so I'm not
confident that clay Higgins is going to
be held accountable for that but
certainly not indicative of Law and
Order that's for damn sure we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P you can call the voicemail any
time of day any day you want the Eggman
called then this is sort of funny the
Eggman seems to have been convinced by
urine drinker Christopher key on
Tuesday's show this is funny
hey I think you are a little bit hard on
Christopher key yesterday
I drink my urine seasoned with Nesquik
powder there one glass Two Scoops in
this quick it's almost like a chocolatey
lemon Shake it's perfect unless it's
fresh right out of the spicket then no
seasoning needed but it's a really hard
trick leaning back like that it's called
the bubbler
Shalom all right so the uh the Eggman of
course is joking but I have not gotten
this sort of reaction to any interview
that we've done for a really long time
people disgusted excited titillated
unable to stop laughing people wrote to
me saying they listened to this uh
during that interview the the
Christopher key interview while they
were driving to work in the morning and
had to pull over from laughter
particularly when I said I had him uh
spotted more as a manuka honey guy for
sweetening the urine rather than Stevia
but anyway that'll be a conversation for
a different day on sweeteners wild stuff
without a doubt we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today we will talk
about Rudy Giuliani being hit with yet
another lawsuit how many are there at
this point uh we also will discuss
Montana becoming the first U.S state to
ban Tick Tock and we will talk about the
latest Revelations related to gnome
Chomsky and Jeffrey Epstein they are
becoming of concern to many in our
audience all of those stories reason
more on the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad join the money making on the
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com I
will see you then for tomorrow on the
Friday show
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it's springtime
you're outside more it is time for
sunscreen but stay away from the
chemical sunscreens with ingredients
that can irritate skin cause hormonal
disruption or Worse instead use mineral
sunscreen by Ginger armor which is just
as effective you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at gingerarmor.com the link is
down below